also meine
drei Fragen an dich heute
die erste Frage ist du hast ja 2009
dieses Weihnachtsvideo für uns gemacht
und
war das für dich ein großer Aufwand
diese ganzen Videos zusammen zu
schneiden also hat dass sie wirklich
nerven gekostet oder war das einfach nur
so locker flockiger Aktion für dich und
war nicht so anstrengend oder so also ne
ja
die zweite Frage ist
du hattest ja auch diese Aktion mit
deinem Namen wie soll ich meinen Kanal
nennen oder da waren viele coole Namen
dabei
z.B wir haben ein paar sogar besser
gefallen als
frechante Folie an sich ich finde z.B
Orgasmus es waren da musste ich mich
Schrott lang weil sie das gehört habe
und wie geht's dir eigentlich dabei also
wie geht's dir was sagst du wer hätte
dir lieber einen anderen Namen besser
gefallen oder warst du schon auch lieber
auf Frechheit der Folie oder hat er
hattest du einen eigenen Favorit sag ich
jetzt mal bei den Anderen
und ja die dritte Frage ist
erinnerst du dich noch an den Weihnachts
Assassin in deinem Weihnachtsvideo das
war nämlich ich okay
wollte ich nur fragen wie fandest du das
Video wo ich
in diesem Kostüm getanzt habe in diesem
weißen Kostüm mit diesem klingen Dingern
und so
getanzt habe ja
das war jetzt eigentlich meine Frage
meine letzte Frage ich hoffe du
beantwortest die alle also alle meine
Fragen und ja ich bedanke mich dann auch
bei Click suchen wenn ihr meinen meine
Frage jetzt postet und ja danke schön ne
so viele Fragen waren das jetzt ne dich
jetzt garantiert nicht mehr zusammen
bekommen werde aber ich versuche alles
das erste war glaube ich das
Weihnachtsvideo habe mich dafür gekostet
hat mit dem zusammenschneiden das ist äh
es ging eigentlich es war noch nicht äh
es war da noch nicht so viel so viele
Leute die was geschickt haben und
deswegen waren auch viele gute tolle
Sachen dabei deswegen ging es recht
schnell und es war sehr entspannt die
zweite Frage
kanalname genau ähm
das mit dem freshaltefolie ich hätte den
glaube ich
nicht genommen also ich hatte einen
anderen Favoriten aber der hat jetzt
gewonnen und dann ist es auch okay so
und deswegen bleibt das jetzt auch so
und was war noch so die ob ich dich
gesehen habe ich weiß nicht ob ich dich
ich wüsste jetzt ich glaube ich weiß das
ist nur ganz kurz du machst einmal so
glaube ich nur ne ich habe mir das
nochmal angucken aber ich meine schon
aber ich habe dich jetzt ja nicht
wiedererkannt weil du ja ganz eingeartet
warst da deswegen schon schwer und ich
glaube die andere vergessen
schickst du mir mal zu ich beantworte
dir